they can look forward to a wonderful
movie I think I was a great experience
for me I have a great time doing it we
have a fantastic cast we have the the
skill and the wit and ambition of JJ
Abrams great script by one of our
original screenwriters Larry Kasdan and
I was delighted to be involved I'm proud
to be able to represent this film for
the audience it's too late for them I
mean it's it's over
life as they knew it is is no longer
possible it's it's a you know you've
you've checked in for the for the
biggest e ticket ride there ever was
actually did have a bit of a serious
conversation with Daisy who who inquired
about what the experience was like for
me some centuries ago when when this all
started and I know I said your life will
change and you will get used to it
and you will be by turns happy and
delighted and employed and then you'll
wonder what the hell happened every once
in a while because you you turn from the
natural state of an actor is to observe
life around them
now you have to figure out how to do
that when all anybody is looking at is
you so it's a it's going to be it's a
huge change in your life and I I you
know they're smart enough to know that
themselves
you